hello you're watching swipe from a
rather secretive yep pretty famous
research lab coming up on this week's
show will tries out the latest in
high-tech helmets allowing pilots to see
through planes I step inside a simulator
for a new kind of flying lesson and
we're stringing you along in this week's
games review welcome to swipe this week
from behind the scenes at the UK's
largest defense and security company bae
systems now a lot of the tech being
worked on here is highly sensitive they
don't normally let cameras in so lucky
us we've managed to get access although
we can't show you everything but we can
give you a glimpse of what the future
might look like four pilots his will the
modern fighter jet is packed with
technology and pilots rely on it to give
them the edge but before anything makes
it into the cockpit it needs to be
tested and developed in places like this
one of the most important tests is
called shake and bake it involves
extreme temperatures and massive
vibrations we're taking an item we're
going to bolt it down we're going to
shake it to ensure nothing literally
will fall off so nothing is loose make
sure there's nothing inside the unit we
call it fought foreign object debris in
addition today we're going to take it up
and down in temperature so there's some
stress that goes through every item we
put through this particular test and
that test is important one of the latest
developments to come out of here is this
striker too it's got a special camera to
help improve night vision and a digital
display which should help you see
through the aircraft a tracker system
keeps an eye on where the pilots head is
and the range of information on display
should mean they don't have to look away
from the horizon it's already been
tested in a Eurofighter Typhoon but it
hasn't been used in combat yet if you
have a digital display there it means we
can put sensor information so that can
be situations like an infrared picture
it could be an imaging pot it could be a
radar display
it could be whatever whatever ultimately
we like and if clearly you've got a
sensor located around the aircraft if
that happens to be underneath then you
can give the impression at the parties
essentially looking through the surface
of the aircraft even looking behind them
bae is also working to improve head-up
displays in aircraft these systems
provide crucial information to pilots
and are designed to make them feel safer
in the air but as technology becomes
more advanced are we in danger of
relying on it too much if you imagine
for example the Typhoon's on Quick
Reaction alert if they had a a high-tech
helmet that was made we spoke to the
pilot what happens if that helmet goes
from serviceable enroute to the aircraft
for a scramble or as you plug in and
start the engines then the needs to be
robust backup plans are in place
technology within this industry moves
almost as quickly is the aircraft
themselves so working out what will take
off in the future is hard to predict
sergeant sky news now wills not the only
one getting hands-on with the tech this
week stay with us coming up I'll be
getting to grips with a unique kind of
flight control system but first is a
mini roundup of this week's news in tech
whatsapp now has more than 1 billion
users the messaging app launched six
years ago and allows you to share text
photos and video according to Forbes
more than half of its subscribers joined
up over the last 21 months what's that
was bought by Facebook in 2014 4 12
billion pounds easyjet plans to test out
hybrid planes that use hydrogen fuel
cells the technology should mean
aircraft don't have to use jet engines
to move around on the ground it works by
capturing energy from the planes breaks
when it lands the budget airline thinks
this could save it up to 24 million
pounds a year a project on IndieGoGo
wants to make you aware of invisible
threats in the air you breathe the team
behind the air visual know to say it's
the world's smartest air quality monitor
they claim indoor air quality can be up
to five times worse than outdoor
you can also join up to its global
community with other users tracking air
quality trends if you've got a cat that
goes missing for days on end then this
might be perfect for you sorry I
couldn't help that tab cats is a
tracking device that fixes onto your
pets collar it links up to a handset
which guides you to him or her and
apparently you can track up to four cats
at once
the time has come to reclaim our world
stick around for a full on battle with
aliens in this week's games review now
I've come on board a flight simulator to
have a go on these they're called active
in Sector sticks and luckily I've got a
handy copilot here Phil who's our expert
so over to you feel how do these work ok
so if we start flying active in sectors
and use the geared motor dynamically
change the feel force characteristics of
the stick what that does is provide
dynamic feedback to the pilot depend
upon the mode and condition of the
aircraft is that you moving the stick
now because I'm not it is yes so these
sticks are also electrically linked to
know what that does is provide improved
situational awareness between the pilot
and co-pilot where that's advantageous
is within the commercial environment
where these sticks are now being used on
new civil aircraft ok so these sticks at
the moment are on military jets and soon
they're going to be on commercial planes
but why would you need to link the
sticks of pilots on commercial planes
surely they sit next to each other they
can talk to each other company they can
but again it's all around situational
awareness so between what the pilot and
co-pilot can are putting inputs into the
control so enabling them to both see
what the other is doing and feel what
the other is doing provides better
situational awareness between the pilot
and co-pilot alright so does that make
everything a bit safer then it is all
about safety from a commercial
standpoint as well in the past a number
of aircraft used column and wheel
controls which means the control sit
straight in front of the pilot with
using side sticks that allows them to
free up the space in the cockpit and
gets graded views of the displays as
well so do you have to decide before a
flight who's going to have the upper
hand effectively who's going to have the
control because you're still in control
of this one aren't you luckily though
yep there is pilot in control button
which is used to decide whether or not
the pilot or copilot are in control of
the aircraft but at any point in time
one of the other can take control of the
aircraft and what do you think of my
flying right now I think it's very good
maybe you can get a
a new job as a pilot that simulator felt
a bit like playing a video game which
makes a rather nice segue into this
week's games review here's Andy unravel
as a puzzle platformer in which he plays
a little guy made out of red wool called
Yanni and Yanni he escapes from his his
creators house into various photographs
that she has in places like gardens and
the seaside and they're on a much sort
of larger scale because you only so
small so you'll find yourself
adventuring through a garden full of
giant insects or the seaside full of
giant deadly crabs and it's a puzzle
platformer so a lot of the solutions to
puzzles are based around your ability to
manipulate the environment things like
the rising tide in the seaside you'll be
using floats to create platforms for
yourself it sort of reminds me of a less
relentlessly bleak limbo if any well
played limbo it's sort of like that but
a bit more colorful a bit more cheery so
account is a new entry in the tactical
turn-based strategy XCOM series this one
is set 20 years after the last ex con
game so the last ex con game had you
dealing with an alien invasion as part
of this military group called XCOM the
world you want new is no more now the
aliens are well and truly in charge and
the ExCom is a kind of a resistance
group and you're very much on the back
foot switch sort of changes the dynamic
quite a lot the levels and this one are
procedurally generated so as a wide
variety of environments excuse me
fighting in and this is true there's a
lot more emphasis now on time so you'll
have to make tactical decisions a lot
more quickly and it kind of forces you
to make quick decisions and be a bit
more reckless and a bit more risky with
your strategy which is something i think
strategy fans are going to enjoy
so don't light is the first person
zombie game that came out towards the
started last year but it's now getting a
massive expansion called the following
which moves things out of the cities of
the first game and into a sort of big
expensive countryside and the big change
that they've done for this apart from
the fact that the environments is a lot
more open is they've given you a vehicle
to move around in there you've got a
buggy which you can use to drive around
and that really changes up the way that
you play because before it was a lot
about parkour and moving around the city
using your arms and legs and jumping
around whereas now it's a lot more about
driving so it kind of it changes up the
way that you play the game and also you
spend a lot more time running over
zombies rather than just hitting them
with bits of wood but dying light was a
great kind of sleeper hit from last year
and it's really good to see more from
their game
well now that everyone's gone home it's
my time with the helmet see you again
next week the line